(rock music)
- It's time for tonight's HashtagWars.
(audience applause)
(synthesizer music)
- Michael Jordan and Pippen the musical.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience applause)
- The Sklar Mothers
(laughter)
(audience applause)
- Points. All right.
- Bella and Sebastian Bach
- [Chris] Points, nice!
(audience applause)
Kyle.
- Merriam Webster, but
Webster the little black kid.
(audience applause)
- [Chris] Of course, of course. Points.
- Hall and Scrotes.
(audience applause)
- [Chris] Yeah, points. Doug.
(laughter)
- [Chris] Man eater still works.
Man eater still totally works. Doug.
- Thelma and Louis C.K.
(audience applause)
- [Chris] Okay, points. Kyle.
- Sonny and a chair.
(buzzer)
- [Chris] Yes.
(synthesizer music)
- [Chris] Yes, Mike.
- G.I. Trader Joe's.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience applause)
Heather.
- Gepard DTF.
- [Chris] Yes, points. Adam.
- Ikan Hasbob's Burgers.
- [Chris] Yes, points. Mike.
- IKEA and Peele.
- [Chris] Yes, points. Heather.
- To Catch a Tumbler.
(laughter)
- [Chris] Points. Adam.
- Lena Dunham Warrior Princess.
- [Chris] Yes, points. Mike.
- How I Sexted Your Mother.
(laughter)
- [Chris] Yes.
(synthesizer music)
- Emovember.
- Yes, points. Tom.
- Million Manwich March
- Oh.
- I don't want them. I don't
want them. I don't want them.
- [Chris] Good. No points. Cameron.
- No Bleep Tober.
- Yes, points. Tom.
- Dubstepember.
(laughter)
- Points.
(audience applause)
Cameron.
- Yeah it's the first date,
but I'm ready to Bleep tober.
- [Chris] Points.
(audience applause)
Tom.
- Frovember. Which is where
you tease out your pubes.
(laughter)
- [Chris] I'm listening.
- It's where you tease out your pubes
for mustache awareness.
(laughter)
- Points.
(synthesizer music)
- [Chris] Emily Heller.
- Six Flags and they all
have swastikas on them.
(audience applause)
- Okay, points. That's
a very bad theme park.
Very bad theme park.
- It's bad.
- [Chris] Tim.
- One Flag.
- Yes, point.
(laughter)
- Two Flags. Well wait, you've
got to swim between them.
(laughter)
- [Chris] Okay. Points.
(audience applause)
Tim.
- Pregoland.
- Yes, points. Emily.
- Jurassic Park. People
died, there were no rides.
- [Chris] Yeah, points.
(audience applause)
Rhys.
- World War II Land. If
the Americans turn up light
they get in half price.
- Okay, good.
(audience applause)
Oh, bleep!
I'm sorry, I'm going to have to request
your green card be handed over.